[Musica]
[Applauso]
siete mai sentiti
un pezzo di ricambio a lavoro o un
inutile ingranaggio
o uno di quei bulloni e sgangherati che
non sapete dove mettere
ho una vita
che vi avanza dopo che da ora è provato
a montare un mobile dell'ikea
ecco forse qualcuno di voi qui in sala
non ha mai provato questa sensazione
ma sono abbastanza sicura che la
maggioranza qui fra noi almeno una volta
nella vita
questa sensazione l'ha vissuta
all'inizio della mia carriera
io mi sentivo costretta ad indossare
giacche scure ad utilizzare parole
altisonanti
perché volevo sembrare più professionale
serie
ma mi sentivo a disagio
non ero io e soprattutto sapevo che non
stavo facendo un buon lavoro
tante parole pochi contenuti che spesso
si trasformavano in qualcosa di freddo
burocratico alienante
spersonalizzato
oggi io mi occupo di recruitment e la
mia missione è portare colore
all'interno delle aziende
è un lavoro un po particolare vi
assicuro che non sono una pittrice
magari qualcuno qui l'ha pensato ma
capirete fra un po
il mio compito oggi è quello di togliere
questo velo grigio di serietà che spesso
e volentieri le persone pensano di dover
indossare quando vengono assunte in
un'azienda
ecco io
sicuramente ci stiamo trovando di fronte
ad un momento di grande difficoltà
perché da una parte abbiamo delle
aziende che stanno lamentando la carenza
di candidature quindi si apre un divario
e dall'altro abbiamo dei candidati
candidati che cercano semplicemente un
lavoro per sognare per essere felici
un divario che si apre perché ancora
oggi nel mondo del lavoro sembra che sia
più importante la competenza piuttosto
che la persona
ecco vedete io mi sono sentita inutile
esattamente come quel bullone e
decapitato ancor prima di entrare nel
mondo del lavoro
durante il mio primissimo colloquio
io mi ero candidata per entrare
nell'area marketing di un'agenzia
interinale
ero gasatissima carica di entusiasmo
e non vedevo l'ora di fare questo
colloquio
perché io sapevo che avrebbe potuto
aprirmi le porte del futuro
ero appena laureata
onestamente non avevo le idee molto
chiare su chi sarei diventata da grande
ed ero anche un po confusa diciamocelo
però avevo tanta voglia di spaccare
io desideravo la mia autonomia
e non vedevo l'ora di entrare nel mondo
dei grandi per poter dimostrare il mio
valore
peccato che le cose non andavano
esattamente in questo modo perché la
persona che mi fece il colloquio
guardando il mio curriculum e
diciamocela in una maniera anche un po
schifata sì senza mai guardarsi negli
occhi
mi disse ma tu non sai far nulla perché
sei qui
e io ho dentro di me pensavo cavolo ci
risiamo la solita storia dello stagista
con esperienza
feci un bel respiro e mentre stiamo per
rispondere mi blocco e mi disse tu farai
fatica a trovare un lavoro perché ci
sono tanti tuoi coetanei che ad oggi
hanno già realizzato qualcosa di serio
mi dispiace non sei la persona giusta
per noi
ragazzi fine del colloquio durò due al
massimo cinque minuti
e il mio primo tentativo di entrare nel
mondo dei grandi si rivelò un disastro
il risultato
io avevo 25 anni e mi sentivo già
vecchia fallita e inutile e non solo per
il mondo del lavoro ma per il mondo mi
in generale
e se avessi avuto davanti a me lo
spettacolo che abbiamo più fuori
io non avrei visto nulla l'orizzonte
niente
la sapete la storia dell'orizzonte
la prospettiva varia in base a chi
guarda
se adesso uscissimo fuori da qui per
osservare il mondo
potremmo vedere una linea dell'orizzonte
chiara definita è lontana
ma se ci mettessimo tutti a pancia in
giù
potremmo non vedere nulla perché davanti
a noi ci sarebbero alberi montani le
persone case cambia la visuale
ecco pensate ogni volta che un
imprenditore un datore di lavoro scarta
un candidato perché dal suo punto di
vista manca una competenza tecnica si
rivela miope
non riesce a guardare oltre il suo naso
ma soprattutto toglie l'opportunità e la
nega ad una persona di vedere la sua
prospettiva nel futuro
ora io non sto dicendo che dove vanno
bene tutti per qualsiasi ruolo anzi
però ciò che per me davvero importante
è cambiare questa mentalità vecchia
stantia e grigia di tante aziende dove
sembra che l'unica cosa importante sia
un titolo di studi
o una competenza
ma ci rendiamo conto che siamo di fronte
ad una crisi del mondo del lavoro e
della selezione del personale come mai
si era vista prima
e voi sapete perché
perché finalmente gioveranno i giovani
hanno capito che è giusto sperare di
avere una prospettiva di felicità per il
futuro
ora
io al termine del mio colloquio
ero a terra
non avevo alcuna prospettiva
però deciso di fare una cosa
con le lacrime agli occhi anita e
all'interno di una libreria e decisi di
prendere dei libri che potessero
aiutarla a capire qualcosa in più del
mondo della selezione del personale e
ragazzi per fortuna che io non mollo e
ti ho capito nel tempo come
circondarmi delle persone pronte a
tendergli la mano per farmi
oggi
pensando a quell'incontro dico sì mi ha
cambiato la vita ma diciamo anche che
nella stravolta io speravo e sognavo di
diventare la direttrice marketing di una
grandissima multinazionale
e un incontro che è durato solo cinque
minuti mi ha fatto provare delle
emozioni
che hanno cambiato tutto il mio futuro
nei giorni seguenti ma anche nei mesi
seguenti
pensando a quell'incontro io ho dentro
di me sentivo un desiderio ardente di
riscatto
sentivo che dovevo fare qualcosa di
grande
allora sì io voglio ringraziare quella
recruiter
perché è vero me l'ha stravolta la vita
ma è meglio perché ho capito che quel
ruolo di quella recruiter avrei dovuto
ricoprirlo io per non permettere mai più
a nessuno e per nessun motivo al mondo
di sentirsi sbagliato e inutile ho
fallito a colloquio
questo per me è importante allora sì
forse nella vita serve prendere uno
scossone grande per capire che siamo
chiamati a fare qualcosa di grande
oggi
grazie a ciò che imparato da
quell'esperienza ho una mia società di
selezione
e devo ringraziare chi mi ha assunto poi
successivamente perché mi ha dato
fiducia e ha creduto in me prima di me
insieme abbiamo creato un metodo che ci
consente
ci consente di trovare velocemente le
persone si basa sul concetto semplice le
persone hanno un talento e va al di
fuori di curriculum esperienze
competenze che possiamo aver maturato
punto
però ci troviamo di fronte a una
situazione paradossale perché esistono
tante persone che cercano lavoro dei
sogni e tante aziende che lamentano
questa carenza di persone eppure devo
dirvi che ci sono altrettante aziende
che invece hanno fatto questo
cambiamento
sì perché hanno capito che era più
importante in selezionare prima il key e
poi il che cosa prima le attitudini e
poi le competenze e allora sì ora voglio
raccontarvi la storia di due aziende non
posso raccontare era nominare le aziende
ma sono due settori importanti che oggi
soffrono tantissimo questa carenza di
candidati
parliamo di anna
mamma lavora nel settore delle
ristrutturazioni
secondo lei per far crescere una persona
tu devi sviluppare te stesso e uscire
tutta la zona di comfort costantemente è
una persona che quando incontra dei
candidati si chiede com'è che possa
sviluppare il suo potenziale come posso
farla crescere e vincere azienda dei
sogni è vero ci piacerebbe tutti
lavorare lì dentro ebbene si nel 2021
hanno ricevuto 53mila curricula e
assunto
362 persone praticamente una persona al
giorno
e poi c'è la storia di pasqualina che
invece lavora nel settore della
ristorazione avete sentito ristorante
hotel che non riescono ad aprire perché
mi mancano le persone
pasqualina nel 2019 gestiva due locali
ora 9 nel 2020 ha ricevuto 5000
curricula oggi 13.000 bene e qual è il
suo segreto essere sempre in selezione
perché chi l'ha detto che la persona
giusta che arriverà proprio nel momento
in cui tu hai deciso di selezionarla e
soprattutto ha trasformato i suoi
collaboratori in tanti brand ambassador
che cos'è che hanno in comune queste
aziende
al loro interno ci sono delle persone
meravigliose che sono felici si
divertono
sorridono donne e uomini che hanno il
coraggio di essere madri e padri perché
non temono il giudizio e aziende che
stimolano le persone a tirare fuori la
loro personalità perché va bene una ma
mai uniforme
bene queste persone insieme hanno creato
una bandiera che basata sulla loro
personalità sui loro valori e sono fieri
di portarle avanti
e quindi si ragazzo è arrivato il
momento di cambiare
dobbiamo aiutare assolutamente le
persone a capire che fuori ci sono una
molteplicità di opportunità
all'orizzonte
e le aziende hanno il grande onere ed
onore di farlo trasmettere di
trasmetterlo alle persone perché possono
vedere questo orizzonte queste
opportunità soltanto se ci mettono la
loro personalità le loro attitudini la
loro sensibilità
e allora smettiamola di pensare e di
rimanere ancorati alle vecchie abitudini
il mondo del lavoro è cambiato
e non esistono più i collaboratori che
lavorano per le aziende
ci sono adesso le aziende che lavorano
per creare un futuro felice ai loro
collaboratori
e adesso
voglio portarvi dall'altra parte
facciamo un gioco mi porto dall'altra
parte del tavolo nel colloquio di
selezione
e mi rivolgo a te che in questo momento
sta pensando sebbene l'azienda giusto a
te che stai già cercando lavoro voglio
dirti quelle che sono le tre attitudini
necessarie indispensabili per poter
cambiare lavoro la prima deve avere una
grandissima capacità di auto motivarti
guarda che il tuo curriculum perfetto
con le esperienze le competenze non
importa a nessuno
se tu non ci metti la tua grinta se non
ci metti la tua motivazione perché prima
o poi ti spegne
secondo devi scegliere l'azienda sulla
base dei tuoi valori perché inutile
basta metterci una maschera 23 per
sembrare qualcuno di diverso noi siamo
belli così
terzo devi essere responsabile quindi
irresponsabilità unità d'autoironia
avete presente quelle domande che si
fanno a colloquio un po strane dove non
conta la risposta pronta la reazione
la più assurda che ho sentito è questa
se ad esso entrasse un pinguino fuori da
quella porta cosa ti direbbe
ecco le persone che mettono sulle
maschere provano imbarazzo al posto del
recruiting non rispondono
ma chi invece li estera sta giocando è
sul pezzo risponde dice quel pinguino è
venuto qui per dirmi che sono stato
assunto
ok
bene l'essenza è voi a colloquio dovete
essere voi stessi
andate bene così lo mettete più maschere
siete belli
siate voi stessi
e adesso mi rivolgo a te mprenditore che
stai cercando e stai pensando chi
assumere tre azioni importanti
la prima devi trasformare collaboratori
in brand ambassador cioè devi far sì che
siano il simbolo della tua azienda e che
possano raccontare loro l'amore per la
tua azienda 2 crea ambienti divertenti
le persone si divertono all'interno di
un'azienda quindi stimola lei al gioco
non vedere l'orario per la pausa 3
fai in modo di avere sempre un piano di
crescita per tutti i veri campioni e non
sono interessati al contratto o allo
stipendio sono interessati
alla crescita professionale e personale
bene allora possiamo dire adesso che le
nuove generazioni hanno capito che non
vogliono essere più il pezzo di ricambio
di nessuno per fortuna
e allora smettiamola di guardare il loro
curriculum o di guardarle sulla carta
guardiamole negli occhi interessiamoci a
loro
cerchiamo il loro desiderio di riscatto
e soprattutto facciamo sì che siano
unici perché se ci pensate
l'orizzonte noi non lo dobbiamo vedere
l'orizzonte è dentro ognuno di noi
grazie
[Applauso]